big news on hogwarts legacy and the
possibility
of a multiplayer mode avalanche software
is on a major hiring spree and
surprise they're looking for devs with
multiplayer experience
but does that necessarily mean it's for
sure in the game
it's been one of the most requested
features from fans and today
this new information we have certainly
makes it seem like the devs are headed
that direction but i'm still left with a
few questions which we'll dive into here
today
at the time of this recording they have
a total of seven jobs listed on their
site and in today's video we'll take a
look at each of them here
to see exactly what avalanche is looking
for people of the internet
retrorecontour here
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tough
we post videos every week here on
youtube and if you want to stay up to
date on all the latest hogwarts legacy
news theories discussion
and even some old school harry potter
let's plays then consider hitting that
subscribe button so you don't miss any
of our new videos
so what are all these job postings and
what's contained
in them well here's the full list as of
april 14th
2021 we have a lead game system
software engineer lead game ai software
engineer
people partner coordinator for games
cinematic designer
animator for cinematics cinematics
lighting artist
and community manager we're going to
touch on each one of these here today
but i want to start with the two
engineering positions these two jobs are
nearly identical except for two
additions under the
essentials on the ai engineer position
what stands out here regarding
multiplayer is under the
good to have section near the end it's
the second bullet point which reads
quote understanding of the unreal engine
multiplayer and network protocols so
it's important to distinguish here that
this
is not a requirement for the position
it's listed under good to have for a
reason only the items under the
essentials would be the
actual job requirements now if you're
younger and you may not be familiar with
this type of job application language
the good to have is basically something
that would help you stand out more than
others but it's not
necessary for the position if you're
strong enough in other areas you could
still get the job potentially even over
someone who does have the good to have
experience now you're probably thinking
well if this is optional then
doesn't that mean multiplayer isn't
happening with hogwarts legacy well i
don't think it's necessarily that cut
and dry
you see avalanche is a fairly good sized
team already at this point and they've
been working on hogwarts legacy for
quite a few years now
i mean consider that their most recent
game was released all the way back in
so it's entirely possible they already
have plenty of folks
on the team with multiplayer experience
hence why it could be optional for these
two positions
but what about the other job listings
the community manager is being asked to
quote help build an engaged and loyal
community for our upcoming game hogwarts
legacy a new open world
action rpg set in the wizarding world
close quote
community managers are fairly common for
big games these days even single player
ones but i do think it's worth noting
that avalanche is really striving to
build an
active and engaged community around
hogwarts legacy
now that alone i don't think indicates
multiplayer but it is safe to say a
community manager would be
absolutely vital for delivering feedback
when it comes to multiplayer experiences
maybe it's just me and my personal
experience with games but i feel like
some of the most well-known examples of
top-notch and very involved community
managers are usually working with
multiplayer games but again
that could just be me this community
manager position with avalanche
does specifically mention that they're
looking for a quote passionate gamer
with deep knowledge of the industry
particularly rpgs close quote so even if
they do have multiplayer at some point
in this game i really don't think the
single player fans need to worry because
it's completely clear to me that
creating a
strong single player rpg is avalanche's
priority first and foremost
the animator for cinematics and
cinematic lighting designer are both set
to work on hogwarts legacy as well
these jobs are quite technical in nature
similar to the engineering position
and the listings certainly reflect that
there's a lot of interesting
qualifications here but nothing
particularly surprising or newsworthy in
my opinion the people partner
coordinator appears to be focused more
on
internal departments like human
resources so while this person will work
with and
interact with the game developers they
won't have a direct hand in the game
development the cinematic designer will
be working on an
unannounced aaa title so nothing there
for hogwarts legacy fans to analyze
now roughly six months ago i made a
video about 10 features we
need in hogwarts legacy one item i
included
in that list is multiplayer i just i've
seen it from so
many fans who are just begging for this
to be in in some capacity
and at the same time i think it's also a
feature that has a lot of single player
focused fans really kind of concerned
that
no they don't want to go down this road
now if you're looking for my best guess
on the situation
here's what i think when we take
everything into account that we
know about hogwarts legacy particularly
wb's stated desire to focus on live
service games
i've got a whole separate video about
that this is something that came
directly from
wb they want to focus on games as a
service and i have a video that kind of
looks at could they make that work with
hogwarts
legacy so if we take that into account
we take into account the job postings
that mention multiplayer as being a
good to have and the fact that they're
hiring a community manager who would be
vital to any multiplayer focused
experience
i do expect hogwarts legacy will contain
a multiplayer mode
however i don't think it will be there
at launch
in fact this may be something that we
don't even hear about until after the
game is already out
here's how i see it playing out i see
them releasing a separate multiplayer
mode maybe even a few months down the
line after the game's initial launch
a great comparison for what i'm thinking
here would be what sucker punch did with
ghost of tsushima the game is a
fantastic
stand-alone single player experience but
had a separate multiplayer mode released
roughly three months
after the game's launch and they really
did a fantastic job of keeping this
under wraps it was a big surprise to a
lot of people now how was it received
well both the game's single player
and multiplayer mode were very well
received by both fans and critics alike
sucker punch somehow found a way to
honor both single player focused
and multiplayer focused gamers plus the
multiplayer update
was completely free what would a strong
multiplayer experience
look like in hogwarts legacy and how do
they make sure that they do justice to
both the single player fans
and the multiplayer fans first off i
think it would need to be a separate
mode from the main game built from the
ground up with multiplayer in mind
don't get me wrong a hogwarts mmo where
numerous players are exploring the
castle together could absolutely work
but that's
not what hogwarts legacy is designed to
be i think there's still a lot of
hogwarts legacy fans and people watching
the news who
don't fully get that yet this is not an
mmo in the vein of something like world
of warcraft or even destiny it's an
open world action rpg role-playing game
not massively multiplayer online
role-playing game
instead i think a sucker-punch-like
approach of making a completely separate
mode would work best for avalanche here
there are
three major areas where i can see
multiplayer being absolutely phenomenal
for hogwarts legacy number one
quidditch number two dueling and number
three
cooperative missions quidditch would be
perfect and an obvious fit because it's
a sport with multiple positions involved
avalanche could have a mode where we
take control of an entire team against
another human opponent
but they could also take it a step
further by having us control individual
players instead of the entire team which
would make it possible for up to 14
total
players when you include both teams and
all the quidditch positions
they could have different ranks and
leagues plus the customization potential
here would be
incredible when you consider the
possibility of having the professional
quidditch teams different locations for
the matches
broom and gear customization it just so
much more
i could also see dueling being pretty
fun for some 1v1 competitive action
i think here they would want to make
sure they focus on making this a highly
skill based competition
probably based on precision and timing
and then to me the star of the show
would be a cooperative mode that would
see wizards and witches team up in
raid-like
cooperative activities overall i think
the biggest thing here is that avalanche
would need to do what feels right for
the world and the type of gameplay
system that they have in place which we
don't really know a lot about that yet
it's also possible the multiplayer modes
could be added down the line as part of
multiple dlcs rather than just one big
post launch update and guys i really
want to hear from you all on this one
too
do you think this means we are getting
multiplayer and do you want multiplayer
more importantly
if you missed that video i mentioned
earlier about the top 10 features we
need in hogwarts legacy check out the
video on the right side of your screen
now or maybe you're in the mood for
theorizing like the harry potter days
then you can check out the video on the
left side of the screen for my own
theory on the hogwarts legacy storyline
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon